Buonasera, buonasera a tutti
Benvenuti all'Arena di Verona
Partiamo da un filmato
Eccoci di nuovo qua con la storia di
Chiara e Fedez
Benvenuti Chiara
Benvenuto Fedez
Ciao Maria
Fedez ha deciso di cantarti una canzone
Prego Fedez
Biondi i tuoi capelli, azzurri i tuoi occhi
sei la mia raviolona, che nessuno ti tocchi
non servono anelli, per tenerci assieme
ma per comprarti sto brillocco, ho venduto anche un rene
sei matto!
mi vuoi sposare raviolo?
raviolo?!
raviolo dove sei?
sono qui raviolo!!
sei matto!
SI! SI!
YES!
OUI!
si conclude qui un altro trono
grazie ragazzi per averci fatto emozionare
in collegamento c'é una persona che vorrebbe dire qualcosa
si Maria guarda io volevo solo dire che sono molto molto felice per loro
sono veramente una bellissima coppia
molto originale tra l'altro la scelta dell'Arena di Verona
ma non l'aveva mai fatta nessuno la proposta lí eh
scusa sono un pó inacidita perché comunque sto aspettando la proposta di Andrea
che peró ha i suoi tempi, poverino é anche più piccolo
prima o poi arriverà anche per me eh, state pronti
This is the most amazing day in my life guys, I'm so happy right now
and I, ho contattato già Giovanni perché sarà lo sponsor ufficiale delle nostre nozze a base di ravioli
cioè la cosa che é veramente amazing é che é il momento più bello della mia vita
e non ho un telefono in mano!
quindi ragazzi veramente la tecnologia deve stare fuori da questi momenti
tanto ci sono 700 cameraman che hanno ripreso e sono contenta così
grazie a tutti per averci seguito
si peró muovetevi a farmi la foto che mi sta venendo un crampo alla mano
alla prossima puntata, ciao.